on peut par exemple savoir est ce que la
personne
ait beaucoup boire de l'alcool donc on
veut pouvoir dire ce qu'on va pouvoir
catégoriser cette personne nation si
l'ajout relocalisation par exemple
indiqué qu'elle verserait sac qu'elle va
souvent dans les bars
[Musique]
à chaque fois qu'on veut télécharger une
application mais il va falloir comme
utilisateur acquiescé à des conditions
d'utilisation une politique de
confidentialité être intéressés lequel
l'application l'implant quelque sorte
nous donner nous demander de récolter
des données de géolocalisation il
yad'autres manable dont les applications
peuvent également avoir accès à
certaines formes de localisation et que
ça peut être à travers l'adresse ip d'où
ce qu'on veut se connecter donc ça c'est
l'adresse l'adresse un peu d'un appareil
mobile sur un réseau et sur internet
donc qui peut donner une
indication géographique
approximative
mais sinon également même si le module
gps n'est pas activé pour avoir du
réseau il faut se connecter à des tours
cellulaires la triangulation et à
travers les différents tours celle là
peut également donner une idée de notre
localisation
[Musique]
toutes ces informations leur sont en
fait des informations qui qui peuvent
aider différentes compagnies
principalement à des fins publicitaires
donc pour pousser de la publicité ciblée
c'est une personne qui va régulièrement
à l'hôpital mais l'on peut dire à
peut-être que c'est quelqu'un qui risque
d'avoir des problèmes de santé peut-être
qu'on peut
aiguiller vers des publicités qui sont
un peu plus pharmaceutique donc il peut
c'est là que toutes ces informations ne
peuvent être extrêmement utile pour des
annonces à bhl
[Musique]
nos lois sont très mal adaptés pour
répondre à ce contexte de collecte de
données le sait qu'on ne peut d'un sens
régulateur qui peut émettre un jugement
le commissaire à la vie privée du canada
pour y mettre des recommandations donc
et puis après sa baisse et il faut y
aller au cas par cas mais il n'y a pas
un cadre qui est qui est très clair et
défini c'est quelque chose qui on
l'espère va se résorber assez rapidement
dans l'optique où ce que à la fois au
québec et au canada
il y à des démarches en ce moment pour
mettre à jour ses loups alors matière de
protection de la vie privée par contre
qu'est ce qu'on se rend compte
c'est que il ya quand même une tension
qui existe ici donc on veut dire d'une
part oui on veut protéger la vie privée
des citoyens ont voté j'ai cessé de
donner l'heure et puis d'un autre côté
les lyrics petites moyennes et même les
grandes entreprises on dira écoutez nous
on a aussi besoin de récolter ces
données le pour que nous pour que nos
produits soient rentables on se retrouve
avec la protection de la vie privée
contre cette fameuse valeur de
l'innovation et celle souvent qu est l
le bop blessé un peu
[Musique]
il y a justement plusieurs systèmes
d'opération dont la pauvre je pense car
dréossi et ont intégré à même leur
système d'opération
une manière de bleu qui un peu c'est ce
pistage leur part les différentes
applications donc ça c'est très
important et à chaque fois qu'il ya un
petit peuple qui demande de demander à
l'application de ne pas vous suivre
demandez à l'application de ne pas vous
suivre il ya des limites à ce parce que
les applications commence à trouver des
manières de bail passé d'où le conseil
de dire si on n'utilise pas une
application
c'est une bonne pratique de supprimer
cette application leur parce que on
s'est vite en fait une source de données
qui peut qui prêtent mal gérée par la
compagnie